hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game you guys suggested from the
sixth round of the US Championship 2022
it is a Han smoke and Iman vs Ray Robson
and it uh very nicely shows how uh today
in 2022 it is not as easy to attack as
it would be for example in uh in 1922 uh
where all sorts of attacks were just
left unpunished so let's dive straight
into it and see what happened here and
it features a very cool line there are
only a few games played in this line uh
in in top tier chest so here uh Hans has
the white pieces and he opens with D4
uh we have Knight to F6 by Robson C4 E6
and now the immediate Bishop to F4 now
this is a very very rare uh but it has
been played by by some very very strong
um players like do that up or to avoida
Sheikh mendonca and of course Magnus
Carlsen so it is not completely
unexplored territory we have pawned a D5
striking in the center C captures on D5
Knight captures now attacking the bishop
Bishop G3 and pawn to C5 striking
against White Center with E4 chasing
away the Knight and the Knight to F6 and
here we have Knight the D2 and already
it seems like black is um in a position
where he can just grab a pawn but it
could be it could be dangerous uh for
example if Pawn captures then E5 comes
and after the Knight moves then let's
Knight let's [ __ ] to F3 and the black
will always have a problem of this Pawn
controlling all of these very important
squares the bishop will come to D3 so
the black king will not be very safe on
the king side at some point black will
have to
and I deal with this with a move like F6
so instead here Knight the C6 just
continuing development and it is now as
of move 7 that we have a completely new
game uh so let's see what Hans prepared
here D characters on C5 Bishop captures
and now Pawn to E5 so he does win the E5
Square Knight to the D5 and the Knight
to G to F3 we have Castles by uh Robson
and now Pawn to A3 as all of the pieces
are uh eyeing that b for square plus It
prepares spawn to B4 so B6 now preparing
to develop the light score bishop and
the Knight to E4 makes sense as you
wanna I get the Knight of these squares
at some point uh and pawn to A5 now uh
fighting against the whites B for
attempt and here we have Rook the C1 you
could also capture the bishop and it is
a very nice piece but captures captures
and then you're really never getting
that b for moving so after A5 we have
rooked the C1 now just uh preparing to
win a pawn here and Knight seat the E7
and this is now very very exciting stuff
can the can the knight uh the bishop and
the pawn be captured yes but uh hans's
King is still in the middle of the board
so let's say you capture this capture
and you capture with the Rook
uh you develop the queen with Tempo uh
attacking the rook and once The Rook
moves you also have to guard the B2 Pawn
then rook d8 and black gets all of this
development with the white King still on
E1 this would uh be very uh very unsafe
so instead just Bishop to D3 continuing
development and now Bishop to A6 uh
controlling this diagonal also preparing
a trade of light score Bishops so catras
counters and now Hans finally castles
with Queen to A8 uh the queen now has
full control over this diagonal as the
light score Bishops have left the board
also Now The Rook is now protected Rook
the E1 and now Knight the F5 putting
pressure on the bishop here and here
Hans just goes Knight to H4 he wants to
grab the grab the Knight and ruin black
spawn structure here so Knight captures
on G3 H captors and now Bishop to E7
putting pressure on the Knight here and
just Queen to H5 and now you can see
that Hans has some ideas of attacking
the black king both of the knights are
here to the queen is here
if the if the pawns start marching up
the board could be very dangerous but
black says Nope not a problem just Pawn
to B5 with Knight to F3 now Shifting the
Knight over to G5 and Rook to C6 Now The
Rook wasn't really doing all that much
on A6 and now you are contesting the
white rook and C1 and the only open or
not the only but on the open C file so
Rook C to D1 uh not agreeing to the
trade plus also you might have some
ideas of maybe getting this Rook into
the attack at some point but Rook the C2
and now you can see that the Rook here
very nicely controls the second Rank and
with the queen controlling this diagonal
it could be a very nice attacking s
asset so here Pawn to B3 and Rook A2
just going after that pawn it would be
maybe a bit too dangerous to play Bishop
captures on A3 uh as then there are all
sorts of tricky ideas like Rook cat
person D5 as you don't want the Knight
Guardian the F6 Square for example Queen
captures and now Knight G2 Knight F2 G5
could be very very dangerous now if H6
there's even Knight to F6 with check and
now if G captures then you can play
Queen captures and if F captures them
Queen captures on G5 you you cannot play
anything else but here it would just be
basically a force to draw a queen to H6
checking G8 Queen G5 check and so on
so well it can be played uh Robson feels
that he can achieve more but Rook to A2
and now Knight to D4 and okay the B5
Pawn is hanging but also a hunts made
room for this Pawn to start marching
forward with F4 and F5 with real
captures on A3 Ray grabs the pawn and
now Pawn to F4 uh and okay we have
rooked the A2 here a most interesting
idea for black would be Bishop to B4 but
with all of these Knights and the Queen
and Pawns in front of your king you just
feel a bit uneasy going after material
point is that now The Rook cannot be
saved if you if you play something like
rookie too then uh just Knight the C3
goes after the Rooks and after Knight
captures Bishop captures now you are
just a very very happy here you've
cleared the path for the White Queen and
even if for example Knight captures on
B5 you can play Rook cap for some B3 and
black is left with a with a past a pawn
so this is one way to do it and if you
don't play rookie 2 explain Rook F1 then
just Knight the E3 is very very
unpleasant one of the Rooks will now
hang so Bishop B4 most unpleasant here
but we have rooked the A2 which means
now if those Knights move uh White will
get checkmated on the G2 square and here
uh the safe way to play this is just to
plain Knight captures on B5
and you you continue playing this then
the Knight gets access to D6 and so on
still the B3 Pawn is weak and you will
have to worry about the past day pawn
but it would be the safest course of
action but Hans goes for F5 and not the
entire position just you know starts
screaming basically because what what is
black to do can this even be played uh
what if F6 is played uh it is is rages
getting checkmated here well as it turns
out uh he just plays Knight the C3 and
it's a very nice move it attacks the
Knight it attacks The Rook of course if
the Knight moves then a queen captures
on G2 is just Checkmate so Hans has to
decide what to do here and there's no
easy wheat way to meet this Knight the
C3 idea so Hans plays Ponte F6 he
continues the attack completely
disregards the Knight but now even
though this is a fine attempt there is a
line only one and you have to play very
very precisely on each move of the line
to survive this and retain a better
position so so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the only
winning idea for black while I give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on not playing G
captures on F6 and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Bishop
captures on F6 that's the only move the
problem with the G captures is that uh
well you just play e captures and F6 and
now you're just getting destroyed the
queen G5 check followed by Queen G7
Checkmate or even if you give up the
bishop here just Knight captures and F6
with check King G7 and then Knight to F5
with a very nice a very nice checkmating
idea if King captures an F6 Queen H6
checking captures on F5 Rook the E5 with
Chair King captures an E5 and queen the
F for checkmate is only one of the lines
that check made the black king so
congratulations to everyone who spotted
Bishop captures on F6 it is in fact the
only move that gives black the advantage
we have characters with the Knight and
F6 with check now again you cannot move
the king otherwise you get checkmate you
do have to open up the black king and
now point is if characters then this is
still Checkmate hope none of you
um uh you know missed this so instead
after this Knight captures uh after G
captures an F6 we have Knight the F3
this blocks Checkmate but now how is
Hans to continue the game
uh well uh and also how is the rate to
continue the game problem is uh if you
play something like F5 which uh okay
this could be an issue but if you play a
five then Queen G5 check and the Hans
always has a Perpetual not much to worry
about here so you have to play it very
very precisely here after this Knight to
F3 move and uh Ray does he plays in a
rook captures on D1 and now again how do
you continue uh if you well there's
really not all that much to try he
captures and F6 is the only serious
attempt now threatening Checkmate but
now King the h8 uh saying that okay if
you play uh something like Queen to G5
then Rook G8 and there is no Checkmate
there is no attack anymore so Hans grabs
back the Knight Rook captures on D1 and
now Rook to G8 and Ken Hans continue
this attack somehow first he plays King
to H2 he has to defend the G3 Pawn now
comes Queen to E4 now Robson wants to
play Queen to E2 and threaten Checkmate
this way with Hans having a no way of
actually continuing this even if you
captured upon an F7 uh there's the very
annoying Queen captures on F3 and now
you just resign there's really no more
you can play here
so after Queen to E4 uh rooked D7 very
nicely played and now we have Queen to
E2 and Robson goes after Checkmate uh
and now again saying of course none of
this is possible because you have to
defend against Checkmate Queen to H3 is
played but now we have the very simple
and elegant Queen captures on F3 and now
okay Hans is not not done material as
um and now both players have a a queen
oh he's down a full Rook sorry about
that uh the problem is after Rook
captures an F7 which was played in the
game here Robson just played Rook
captures on G2 and he was in this
position on move 35 that Hans moken
Neiman resigned in the game as now there
is nothing more to be done here it seems
like he can trade down and now the
material is equal the problem is Queen
H5 check and after Queen H3 just pick up
the Rook on F7 and that's all there is
to it and if you don't capture The Rook
of course you can play King H1 but then
Queen to F1 is checkmate
uh so just a very very uh short game and
it seems like I mean look at this the
two Rooks the maybe even the possibility
of lifting some of those Rooks the
knights very nicely place the pawns here
ready to be pushed to F6 the queen on H5
so it seems like you have everything uh
for this for the attack to be successful
but uh you do it's just almost
everything it's not everything and there
is that one line that allows Rey to take
the win he found it and that's why he
won this very nice game uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh if you have any other of your
favorites from the US Championship do uh
use hashtag suggestion and I will go
over them uh so looking forward to that
I would like to thank Frank Brown Bjorn
Bartel Ellen winnery uh congratulations
Dr tacon and Francis air for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
and thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions such as this
one uh and whatever else happens in the
chest world uh so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day